the list trust whatever whether people
like her or not was offering a different
set of ideas about how the country
should be run and she actually attempted
to put them in place why was she not
able to actually stay in power long
enough to even see some of those ideas
being implemented there is a social and
economic Orthodoxy which exists if you
if a government was to DARE go against
it you know they would be closed down
pretty quick but it did feel a bit
strange that you know we were up against
the White House we were up against the
world Bank the IMF uh Bank of England
the opposition there was a huge uh
opposition to everything that she was
doing you know when you see this lack of
leadership the lack of spine that we
have across all parties you got to blame
the candidates Department you know where
are they finding these people a third of
our parliamentarians are
unemployable U you know just you know
where do we find them you know they
could run a bath half of
[Music]
them hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Francis Foster I'm Constantin kiss
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our fantastic guest today is a
recently retired government adviser so
he can be honest and the author of the
bloom review Colin Bloom welcome to
trigonometry thank you for having I will
say that the review you are the offer of
you've got here you worked on it for
four years as a review to Faith in the
UK very interesting subject some uh
difficult and also interesting questions
within that uh and of course you were
most recently an adviser to one list
truss uh so we'll talk about all of that
but before we do tell everybody a little
bit more about your background how are
you where you are what's been your
journey through life thank you fantastic
to be on the show and um I've been
listening to trigonom R since I think
the very very beginning now black
curtain room yeah I remember I mean like
I I remember I think probably 50
episodes ago something like that I
remember when this was built um so you
know and congratulations on all the
amazing progress that you've made in
this uh uh with the podcast so bit of
background to me I spent some time in
Industry I spent some time working in
the not for-profit sector but the
probably the best part of my life the
most productive part of my life um has
been in politics and I was um
International secretary for the
conservative party director of the
conservative party I ran the
Conservative Christian Fellowship for uh
a number of years um Boris appointed me
to be the government's Faith advisor in
2019 I wrote this report and then last
year I worked for um uh prime minister
truss uh for all of seven weeks and uh
and then the report came out earlier
this year and then you know I've now
taken a step back and will be
uh focusing on other things and
obviously I mean look at me I'm far too
young to retire so yes I have retired
from government but not uh um I've not
retired um from life that's really good
to hear um we'll do things I suppose in
that order uh we'll come to the report
and Faith later I think a really
important subject actually um but before
we do you mentioned the seven weeks of
the list trust Premiership uh and I'll
ask you the question that I think
everybody wants to know which is what
happened well it was fairly chaotic um I
mean that's that's not a you know I
won't I won't be breaking any uh any
secrets there look and on a personal
level I like Liz I've got you know I'm
not going to say a bad word um about her
I think uh um I think she's a you know
very decent very uh very kind um person
I would consider her a friend um the
time that she had you remember it came
after the came at the end of a very
groing
two months of campaigning for uh who was
going to get the the leadership of uh
the conservative
party that came after all of the chaos
of is Boris going to resign is he not
going to resign you know is he going to
stay in office what's going to happen to
the Boris uh Administration and that
came after all of the coid and the you
know and we we've had so it's it
wouldn't be fair to say that just those
seven weeks were chaos I mean I've been
around since 2010 working either in cchq
or in uh uh or in number 10 or elsewhere
uh it's been chaos pretty much since
2015 I mean I would say that when no 20
2016 was when brexit happened um and
things were fairly well ordered and
pretty well run then after brexit when
Theresa May came in and then Boris came
in and then coid and then Liz and then
Richie uh that was chaos I mean it was
literally just fighting fires one day to
to to to the next and I think in the
future when the history books are
written we will look back and just as
certainly I'm a you know I'm a center
right
conservative uh um free market
capitalist you know I mean that's kind
of I'm not I'm not ashamed of that um we
will look back and go we squandered not
just a huge majority since
2017 after their election um but we
squandered the opportunity to govern I
think really well since 2016 I think but
what happened with with Liz trust
specifically the reason I ask is uh I
think on the day that she was elected uh
Lord Frost was sitting in the chair that
you're sitting in and do you remember
this he came in all chipper he was
excited and we were excited CU you know
any change is exciting and also the list
trust whatever whether people like her
or not was offering a different set of
ideas about how the country should be
run and she actually attempted to put
them in place why was she not able to
actually stay in power long enough to
even see some of those ideas being
implemented well I mean look my take on
it is that in in August of last year of
201 uh 22 I think it was fairly obvious
that she was going to win the leadership
election so uh you know those of us that
were working on her campaign could see
that you know the numbers were were were
very strong um and as it turns out you
know she she won reasonably uh
convincingly now that vote was only with
the conservative members so there was a
campaign that you know richy's team were
going up and down the country trying to
get conservative um U members uh to vote
for Rishi and lizz's team were doing the
same um and the numbers were were pretty
healthy for Liz so I'm hypo I'm you know
I suspect as I don't know for for sure
but I suspect they knew the gig was up
when we did that was sometime in August
so they went through the motions and and
said okay you know yes they you know
they drove to the line and they fought
to win uh uh you know they thought that
they were uh they had to put in a good
showing but they probably knew it was a
death march from the beginning of August
then September Comes um the announcement
is made Liz
wins uh she goes to see the queen I
think on the was it the 5ifth or the 6th
of September I think the queen dies I
think was it the 8th of September um and
then we have 10 days of not very much um
and then chaos even more chaos than
we've ever had uh before and I don't
necessarily blameless for that those
will probably get me into trouble with
some of you know my friends who don't
agree with me on this but I think I
think it was inevitable when you've got
somebody who is stepping outside of both
the economic and social Orthodoxy that
is was expected of her and I and I and I
make this point you know if you were to
take all of the G7 leaders of you know
macron Trudeau Biden um
Schulz alanazi in Australia or Jinder
Ren as it was uh in New Zealand there's
not any real difference in either social
policy or Economic Policy between any of
them and there's and they're all by the
way on on the Cent left so here you've
got a center right member of the G7
who's saying no we're going to you know
we're going to cut spending we're going
to lower taxes we're going to grow the
economy we've got to break with the
economic Orthodoxy and I'm no Economist
but I mean it sounded good you know that
actually here we can't carry on printing
money we've got to you know we've got to
do something different because I think
as everybody accepts there is an
economic tsunami which is about to hit
the West which we you know which we're
not ready for and so um you know that
would have upset some pretty powerful
people around the world uh and and
locally um of course one second Colin
who are these pretty powerful people
sorry to interrupt because there'll be
people of a conspiratorial nature we say
well this is the world economic Forum
there'll be people you know talking
about shadowy figures I mean who are we
actually talking about well look there
are shadowy figures everywhere even in
the comedy circuit
so so let's not thank you for addressing
that of me but let's not pretend that
you know that shadowy figures don't
exist yes it's not it's it's not
conspiratorial thing to say that there
are shadowy figures there are shadowy
figures everywhere health education
politics comedy wherever um but that's
not what you mean when you talk about
comedy you're not talking about somebody
who's puppeteering in the background
you're talking about I I'm not saying
that there is like I I don't think
there's some sort of you know jepetto
who is a I don't think that there is one
person who is pulling all the strings
and and I'm certainly no conspiracy
theorist but I'm saying that there is an
Orthodoxy and that
Orthodoxy uh may be unspoken it may be
uh Unwritten but it exists and you have
to stick to it because if you step
outside of it you know you you you you
feel the you feel the pain of it so um
and that Orthodoxy I think you know
is largely economic but I think it's
also as I said I think a social
Orthodoxy in terms of uh um you know
Progressive beliefs and I think that um
you know when you have a prime minister
that says no I'm going to do something
slightly different it upsets the markets
it upsets that Orthodoxy it upsets
individuals um and you can see why and
it becomes a bit of a Feeding Frenzy I
mean the last days of trust was um when
she was prime minister um was you know I
mean it was everybody was against her I
mean and and maybe because as I said I'm
not an economist maybe they're right
honestly you know Francis Constantine
maybe they're right maybe I'm wrong but
it did feel a bit strange that you know
we were up against the White House we
were up against the world Bank the IMF
uh the bank of England the opposition
you know other people within the
conservative party you know there was a
there was a huge uh opposition to
everything that she was doing which
seemed to
me um out
of kilter with uh what would be normal I
mean it was just such a such a robust um
response uh to the point that you know I
think on the Friday uh uh the chancellor
quati quing had to fly back from
Washington uh and he was fired I think
on the plane on the way over Jeremy Hunt
was brought in it was too late by then
you know the game the gig was up um but
but so I'm I'm not suggesting any cons
conspiracy what I'm saying is that there
is a social and economic Orthodoxy which
exists if you if a government was to
DARE go against it you know they would
be closed down pretty quick and honestly
tell me where is the social and economic
difference between this government and
that of Biden or Trudeau or macron or
kiss Arma for that matter I suppose the
only one that I can think of off the top
of my head is Maloney in Italy in Italy
yeah yeah but that's pretty much the
only one but the point is well you've
got Hungary as well yeah uh so Victor
Orban in in in Hungary he's definitely
stepping outside of that Orthodoxy but
it's a country with 10 million people I
love Hungary I love hungarians it's not
going to rock the planet if they step
outside of the Orthodoxy when the United
Kingdom still the fifth biggest economy
in the world still the sixth largest
manufacturer in the world London the you
know probably the greatest Capital City
the greatest City on the planet when
that that steps outside that economic
Orthodoxy you know it's going to make
waves and as much as I love Rome and as
much as I love Italy and as much as I
love Hungary um you know we're not
talking in the same league no good point
taken when did you know that things are
not going well was there a particular
moment where you thought to yourself
hang on yeah um Mid August I
think no I would say sometime it was it
was it was very shortly afterwards um
and uh you know and I and I thought that
you know we were just fighting fires all
the time and Party Conference came
around um early October uh
2022 um and by then it was very clear
that you know we were constantly just
putting out fires and no matter what the
party chairman did what the chief whip
did what the uh you know what the prime
minister's chief of staff was doing what
the other cabinet Min ministers were
doing it was all you know it was all
just getting a bit too much and what
were these fires in particular Colin
well you know so we
had let's say Personnel issues with some
members of parliament um uh some of them
were Legacy problems that had come over
from uh from from boris's time as as as
as prime minister um but you know just
getting the support across the back
benches was was was was pretty difficult
so you're fighting your own party at
this point yeah I don't think that's I
don't and I don't think that's
necessarily controversial I think the
the party was fighting
itself pretty much during coid as well
andx yeah well and certainly brexit I
mean the party's position on brexit was
neutral although the Prime Minister
Cameron obviously was uh you know was in
favor of staying and I often think about
you know David was a was a great prime
minister and I really really like and
admire him um you know I I wish he had
stayed out of that argument I wish he
had have said you know what I'm not
going to campaign for one thing or the
other I've got to be the Prime Minister
the rest of you go and campaign fight
for your lives fight for what you
believe um and then when the votes come
in I'll Implement what what you know
what you had but by by this time he'd
already done I think two um uh you know
we we'd had two big uh um you know
national uh
elections uh we had the the first pass
the post one and then we had the uh um
what was the what was the other the
Scottish the Scottish
referendum um we hadn't had referendums
for as long as anyone could remember and
then suddenly three come along at once
and
David supported um you know uh remaining
and it cost him his Premiership and I
think actually you know he he was a very
very good prime minister he was why did
you say that because I don't think
that's how people will remember him and
I I don't really know what I think about
why do you say it was a good CU I'll be
honest you strike me as a guy who's
worked in a conservative party for a
long time you're very nice you're nice
about other people are you just saying
that because you're being nice or or was
he actually a good prime minister and if
so what was it that made him a good
prime minister so look his his his
personal values were were fantastic I
mean there was no Scandal around David
Cameron whilst he was in office there's
been one little thing subsequently with
greensill but when he was in office you
know no hint of any Scandal around him
he's a good family man he was a decent
man um he was very clear about what he
wanted to do what he wanted to achieve I
thought the Coalition and again this
will get me in trouble with some of my
some of my friends um but I actually
thought the Coalition did a pretty good
job I quite you know I quite like Nick
CLE as Deputy Prime Minister and Danny
Alexander those was those were like
Glory times that was a you know there we
had a what felt like a center
right um political Coalition that was
doing things but when then brexit came
along and of course we've not had stable
government since so when I said Cameron
was a good prime
minister you know he did have an air of
stability about him you know there
wasn't the rocking of the boat there
wasn't the major scand scandals there
wasn't the issues that we you know that
we had if you remember he had a you know
pretty good foreign secretary in William
hay to begin with uh and then he won an
first time in I don't know how many
years probably 25 or 30 years he
actually won a majority for the
conservative party we didn't win a
majority in 2010 that's why we had the
Coalition um and the then party chairman
Lord Feldman fantastic fantastic man
great
boss um and you know were bringing about
the kind of reforms that a grownup
political party needed um and then of
course it all just sort of changes over
night and Theresa May comes in in 2016
and um and then you know there were a
lot of people who were very very against
her and against what she stood for she
didn't help herself and then we had this
ridiculous election in 2017 I mean just
ridiculous we should never have done it
Colin do you think part of the problem
was I look at that cons the conservative
party the majority that you won in the
2019 general election is huge
particularly from the red wall and we've
covered that on the show ad norum but
the problem is is that when you then
have a prime minister like Liz truss
saying things like we need to shrink the
government we need to we need to lower
taxes we need to cut public sector etc
etc that is a message that by and large
ain't going to fly in the red wall which
means that you are therefore putting
these MP seats in Jeopardy therefore if
they acting their own best their own
interests they're not going to want to
go for it so I dis I disagree with you
Francis I I think the red
wall um if you said to them do we want
to have more efficient government do we
want to cut waste do you want to have
more more money of your own in your own
pocket do we want to cut taxes the red
wall if you want to put it like that uh
those Northern cons sort of Labor seats
that became conservative that's their
language okay um we won such a massive
majority in 20 uh uh in 2019 because we
had three b's uh sorry the three C's not
the three C's right we had uh no I was
right the first time the the we had uh
BBC I know 3bs 3c's it was BBC we had
Boris enormous Charisma I mean you know
so much Charisma he shifted the dial on
every campaign he's ever been in and
he's he's you know he's a the most once
in a generation charismatic
charismatic uh uh politician love him or
hate him he's going to move the
dial um we also had brexit at that time
brexit was not done a lot of people were
very frustrated and we had Corbin you
know so we had the BBC we had Boris we
had brexit and we had Corbin that that
led to that huge majority that Boris won
in uh in 2019 I think if we were to have
the election with that if Corbin wasn't
the leader of the opposition the
majority wouldn't have been as big if
brexit had been sorted the majority
wouldn't have been as big and if Boris
wasn't Boris and didn't have that
magnetic Charisma that you know that
made him so famous then the majority
wouldn't have been that big there may
not have even been a majority at all you
know for all I know but those were the
three ingredients that meant that we had
this weird landslide that that happened
um and those issues of more efficient
government smaller government lower
taxes going for growth building jobs
those are exactly the sort of things
that um uh people in those Northern
seats want they're not the kind are they
sorry sorry to interrupt Colin I mean
mat Matt Goodwin who's a regular on the
show who I'm sure you're familiar with
uh his argument is that the list trust
economic position uh which by the way I
really I'm I'm a fan of I do think we
need to shrink the size of the state Etc
represents sort of about 7% of the
British public uh most people want you
know high taxes cuz they want High
spending are you sure that that's really
what people in the red wall want well
I mean if you say do you want your uh
resources to be wasted in the way that
they have been wasted on yeah I mean but
you're leading the witness a little bit
maybe but but you know you've got to you
got to think we are we are printing more
money than we can um we can I agree with
you I'm just saying does the red wall
agree with you we are borrowing more
money but I think these are these are
mostly pretty downto
Earth common sense people you know like
Jeff norcot you know what do most people
think I think most people think this you
know most people think you shouldn't
live beyond your means you shouldn't
have a government that's bigger than
what you can afford but we have been
literally you know high on printing
money and borrowing money that we don't
have and who are we saddling we're
saddling your children we're saddling my
children and and our grandchildren with
with you know un uh you know just
unpayable debts
and we have to get to grips with this so
Liz was right we have to have smaller
government you know we have to have a
low tax economy how many politicians
have you heard how many people have you
had sitting in this chair saying we wish
the British economy was like you know or
London was like Singapore on temps do
you know how you get Singapore on temps
is that you have a much more mature
approach to immigration you have smaller
government you probably pay your
politicians a bit more you root out
corruption you deal with Law and Order
in a much more stringent way you deal
with uh uh asylum in a probably a
different way than what we we're
currently doing so they they say the
sound bites this is what we want but
they're not prepared to then do what's
necessary to achieve it and what will be
necessary to achieve it you know we'll
be having a smaller government with a
much more you know much more focused
government um taxing less putting
corporation tax up is a crazy thing to
do you want to drive businesses out you
know I I I just don't understand where
is the conservative in taxing businesses
more than they've ever been taxed before
we should be competing in a global stage
by having no come to the UK you know if
you're a billionaire somewhere in the
world you've probably got a flat here in
London or you've got a house in London
right um we get precisely zero of all of
of their income tax well why would you
pay 50% or
45% you know better to have 5% of
everything than 40% of nothing I mean
any idiot knows this but we we make life
very very difficult for ourselves if we
um if we don't use the assets that we
have like London you know like um uh you
know the stability that we are famous
for uh in a in a successful way and I
think that you know we are we we are in
danger if we don't make some big changes
pretty quickly then I think we're in
danger of
you know creating irreversible problems
for ourselves if we haven't done so
already so you're saying all of these
things which I agree with from an
economic point of view why aren't we
doing it
then well you see that's the that's the
$24 million question right the it's it's
hard it requires political leadership
and I say this in my report there are
certain things that you know we need to
tackle as a nation that is going to
require political leadership it's going
to require courage bravery from our
politicians more than just fine words
they are going to have to see something
through to the end the problem is is
that at the
slightest pressure most of them cave in
you know you saw this recently with the
ministry of justice and I can't remember
what exactly the issue was it might come
to me where it was obvious that they
were going to have to you know change
change Tac it was it was uh uh I
remember it was the guy who had been
convicted and sent to prison and an um
and he he was innocent and he had to
repay the the money that he got
compensation and then they tried to
charge him for bed and board for the 20
odd years he was in prison right and and
you know the newspapers sort of said
this is outrageous and the ministry of
Justice put out a statement which said
um we have no plans to change this and I
was listening to this on the radio and I
and I turned to my wife and I said of
course they're going to change this I
this is like this is ridiculous this is
typical of what I'm talking about and
sure enough within a week the Justice
Minister had announced yes we're going
we're going to change it so what did
they they they they lose on all counts
because they look idiotic to begin with
for not saying not reading the political
runes and saying yes of course we're
going to have to change this this is you
know it's offensive that you would
charge this guy this um and of course we
need to look at it but but then they'd
already put the the press release out to
say that they weren't going to look at
it and then of course then they have to
U-turn there's nothing more obnoxious to
an MP that has to you know grab hold of
the handbrake and do a 180 degree uturn
in the middle of the skid pan which is
exactly what they did so they just look
stupid and and this is um it's going to
require bravery for them to say this is
what we're going to do and we're going
to stick to it um and we don't see much
bravery I'm afraid in in public life we
don't see it from either either of the
two main political parties or uh or or
any of them and um you
know I remember I'm old enough to
remember my political hero is Ronald
Reagan right and um if you ever come to
my house you'll see that we have our
downstairs toilet is uh is it's got all
of the Reagan memorabilia in there he
used to sit in front of a TV screen and
talk to the nation and he was known as
like the great communicator you know the
Gipper and and he would say this is why
we're going to be cutting taxes because
you know we're cutting taxes because in
fact we will raise more money you know
he would talk about things like the
laugher curve and or when the when the
shuttle exploded and he went straight
onto the TV and he spoke to a nation
that was in shock about us not hiding
our you know our mistakes but we do
things in you know making a clear
contrast between Western American values
and the values of the of the of the
Soviet Union and you know he had great
political bravery you know he a great
communicator and we don't have anyone
like that you know but here you come to
the question that I always ask in this
situation which is well I mean the
obvious counter to what you're saying is
just from a devil's advocate perspective
is uh list trust your bravery and look
how that ended number one but there's a
broader thing going on that I really
wanted to ask you about which is I am
very concerned about what you're talking
about uh not only the lack of leadership
um but also particularly on the economic
issue we are not willing to be honest
with ourselves and all we're doing is
pushing the problem down the line onto
people who are not yet born that is
irresponsible but the question I want to
ask you is in a world in which anytime a
prime minister says I intend to cut
spending I intend to lower taxes what
the media do is they come out and say
well when you do this you will kill
people you are killing people you are a
murderer right George Osborne I was on
TV the other day arguing with some woman
who called George George Osborne the
murderer right I asked her when he was
convicted she didn't have an answer but
my my point is we live in a world in
which I don't really know how a
politician is ever going to cut spending
again because if you if you make that
decision you will be saddled with those
images that people will be given in
their heads by the media yeah yeah it's
a tough job right and it shouldn't be
for every body and you know we have this
phrase amongst some friends of mine and
I I btcd you know I blame the candidates
Department um you know when you see this
lack of leadership the lack of spine
that we have across all parties you got
to blame the candidates Department you
know where are they finding these people
you know I would say I'm being very
generous now a third of our
parliamentarians are
unemployable U you know just like you
know where do we find them you know
these people we run we are trusting to
vote on our behalf to run things you
know they can run a bath half of them so
you know we've got to be much clearer
eyed much more focused about what
candidates we're choosing you know um
and then when they're in government they
need to know that their political
leaders those people who are currently
either Shadow ministers or ministers or
secretaries of state or Shadow
secretaries of State have got the spine
and have got their back you know to see
something through they need to explain
to the public why they're doing it the
public aren't stupid you know they're
not stupid if you explain to them this
is why we have to do it and stick to
their lines I'm sure that you know you
you won't win over some of course you're
not you know but you're never going to
win over everybody but you just need to
be able to say this is why we're doing
it and you know what it might be
unpopular but you do all that at the
beginning of a parliament you don't you
know you might not want to do that at
the very end of a parliament but you
need to make these big difficult tough
decisions and take people with you I
think the public are sick of being taken
for fools and you know having
wishy-washy here today gone tomorrow
politicians that are um you know have no
spines I think they're looking for
political leaders there's a guy um
there's a
conservative um Member of Parliament um
northern fellow he was Labor he was a
coal miner Le Anderson Lee Anderson you
know he's phenomenally popular you know
what where did he suddenly spring from
what a guy you know common sense says it
as he sees it takes on that Burke with
the uh megaphone outside Parliament
every time he sees him you know now we
need more people with that kind of
backbone I'm not saying I don't know him
and I don't know his politics I'm sure
he's a fantastic fellow um but we need
more people with that kind of conviction
who are going to stick to their guns and
not get pushed around by the latest you
know fancy Dan you know opinion polls
that might come to the left or to the
right well I hope that that happens
let's move on to something slightly less
controversial which is of course
religion um you are the author of the
bloom review which is uh a review into
faith in this country and and a lot of
the issues that that surround that
before we get into your findings and
some of your conclusions what is Faith
and how is it different from belief uh
what is Faith and what is the purpose of
faith in society it's a that is a great
question so I've done quite a few
interviews about this report already no
one's ever asked me that so the
definition between faith belief and
religion I think is misunderstood and so
in my report I make a very clear
recommendation that government for the
purposes
of um for the purposes of of of
government there should be some working
definitions of what is religion what is
Faith and what is belief um in simple
terms we've all got beliefs you don't
have to have a faith to have a belief
but you do need to have a belief to have
a faith Faith MH um and religion is you
don't necessarily have to have a faith
to have a religion or a
belief yeah
um we have sort of
institutionalized
religious organizations in the UK um and
around the world and then you've got
people so there's a lot more people who
are very spiritual so they would say I
don't I I have a faith but I don't have
a religion a lot of people would say
that you know um a lot of people believe
in God I mean still the vast majority of
people still believe in God what's the
percentage in this country I I think
it's in the' 80s in the ' 80s
interesting um um who say that they
believe in God but it might not be the
god of you know Islam or the god of of
of of Judaism or the god of Christianity
or or Hinduism sism but it might just be
something they believe in something but
they certainly have a belief in
something more than they can see more
than they can touch something
Supernatural
it may be well founded it may be not you
know it's not for me to say but is that
Faith um that would be a that would be a
faith that would be fath that would be a
faith it would also be a belief because
I said you have to have a belief to have
a faith you don't have to have uh a
faith to have a belief so the
humanists and and by the way Andrew
copson if you ever if you ever want a
good guest for your show get Andrew
copson from the humanist this is I like
him you know we get on well he he was
very helpful when I was looking at these
definitions I don't think he necessarily
wanted to be as helpful as he as he was
very helpful because you know he did
help me understand that you know you you
can have
profoundly um worldview beliefs that
that are not rooted in anything
Supernatural they're not rooted in
anything that requires Faith um uh you
know people joke that you know humanism
is um you know it's the it's the
religion for people that have no faith
you know it's kind of um because they
they do have their they have an
Orthodoxy you in that sense
um but yes still the majority of people
in the UK have a faith it it it's for
the first time according to the 2021
census it's less than 50% now are
Christian 7% nearly 8% I think are are
British Muslims and then you've got you
know Hindus and siks and Jews and um and
and Buddhists and others that sort of
make up that difference but for memory I
think it's in the sort of' 70s uh people
who say that they have a faith um and
you know that's very interesting so when
you've got that many people who say
faith is important to them their faith
shapes who they are and what they do and
why they do what they do um and yet
government is so illiterate when it
comes to understanding well what is it
that makes these people tick you know
even the basics of what's the difference
between a Hindu and a sik if if if if a
government official if a civil servant
somebody who's responsible for enacting
a writing policy and then administering
it doesn't know the difference between a
Hindu and a sik then there's something
wrong and what I found was that Faith
literacy in government in the police in
the National Health Service in prison
service in
education was woefully inadequate you
know and when faith is more important to
there are more people with faith than
any other protected characteristic so
you've got more people who have a faith
in the UK than are pregnant than are um
male or female or um
lgbtqi or um disabled or you know I'm
trying to remember what all the
protected characteristics are but but
you know more people have a faith in any
of them and yet faith is the Cinderella
protected characteristic when it comes
to these things and so my my argument
from the very beginning and you know
Boris asked me to do this because I
think he understood from his time as
mayor
that and London is by the way has more
people of Faith than the rest of the
country as a percentage it's it's just
much more diverse that I think he kind
of had that instinct now Boris is many
things a lot of people will criticize
him you know From Here to
Eternity um but he does have an
intellectual curiosity and he does have
an instinct which very few other
politicians will have and he I think had
this sort of instinct well look there is
something that there's a disconnect both
as my time as May and now as you know as
foreign secretary and now as prime
minister that people faith is important
to some people and yet we don't
understand you know we don't understand
it as either government or is uh in
public
life so my report is um 65,000 words
long you know it's a it's a big report
recommendations we did call for evidence
we had 21,000 responses to it you know
there's a lot of work that went into it
an excellent team supporting me from and
academics as well as um some civil
servants and um we produced these
recommendations which hopefully if
either this government or the next
whatever that might look like you know
will adopt and I think it will go some
way to improve the relationship between
government and faith and people of faith
and places of worship I mean just take
for example places of worship we have um
tens of thousands of them and nearly all
places of worship in the UK are schools
of virtue you know whatever your faith
if you go to a place of worship you will
come out of it a better version of
yourself we hope right um they they
contribute to the public good whether
it's in the mosque or the synagogue or
the church or the temple or the Gara
they contribute to the public good
enormously and yet it kind of runs
parallel to every government's oblivious
to it think of all the youth clubs and
the food banks and the self-help groups
and the and the you know Alcoholics
Anonymous and the Cocaine Anonymous and
all these other groups that are run um
out of places of worship they do
phenomenal work and uh I'm very excited
by the work that they're doing you know
I want to Champion them uh um but you
know government are oblivious to it for
the most part and it seems to be an
afterthought whenever they just think oh
gosh you know we need to we saw that in
coid this afterthought you know coid
suddenly happens we need to close down
places of worship well
we had no way of communicating with you
know well who are the how do we get hold
of all the imams and the rabbis and the
um and and the Bishops and the and and
the El Temple Elders how do we get hold
of them well you know it was a um it was
an it was an interesting time because
you just saw immediately at a time of
Crisis we needed these people we needed
the places of worship to act as vaccine
centers and to do all these other things
that they were uh they were doing but
there was no communication there was no
relationship Colin uh a lot of people
have come on this show and they've been
speaking about the decline of
Christianity and the fact that it's
having in our society so would you be
able to tell us a little bit about that
is is Christianity declining and if so
how quickly well it is and it isn't
right so um within the different
denominations within the Christian
Church you know you'll have I mean I
always think of it a bit like a candle
you know when you get to the very top of
the candle very high church and then
you've got kind of different
denominations down the bottom um
Evangelical Church is growing the
Evangelical churches is growing
particularly um the Evangelical Church
of England churches the um uh the
Pentecostal churches are growing the the
you know so some of the more recent
immigrant communities that have brought
their particular um uh flavor of of of
Christian expression they are you know
they're big the Catholic church is doing
pretty well I mean largely um I think
driven by one some people in the Church
of England feeling that they are Church
of England no longer speaks for them on
you know certain issues of of what they
see as morality and also because we had
lots of Eastern Europeans um come to the
UK and they they they started going to
um Catholic churches but it's a mixed
bag so overall we have a um you know we
have a a a state religion if you like in
that uh we have the uh the Church of
England um and
and yes it would be fair to say that
fewer and fewer people are probably um
identifying or definitely fewer and
fewer people identifying as being Church
of England
um however within that if you were to
have a look at it from a from a segment
m mented point of view the different um
communities that within that some are
growing like crazy so if you go to um St
Helen's Bishop's gate just take London
we've got St Helen's Bishop's gate we've
got Holy Trinity bromton packed
absolutely heaving and they've got lots
of satellite churches around London both
of them are doing you know incredible
work and their churches are full and yet
you know you can go to some little
Parish church is not far from here you
might only get a dozen people in there
so it's a really mixed picture
um but what we are seeing is a lot of
particularly genz and Millennials are
saying well I might not want to be
religious but I do want to have a faith
and so they are finding a home in some
um non-conformist or Evangelical
churches um um where where it is you
know perhaps more welcoming it's
certainly very different to a you know a
priest and you know um the Liturgy that
might go on um I mean some uh some
churches are like mini rock concerts I
mean there would be you know the
production
values and I love your set but I mean
they would make your set look positively
CH chill
out get SL off and and and so when
you're when you're you know when you
look at it in the round I think in the
round you would say I would say and I
say so in my report that actually faith
is in pretty good health but it's just
not what it used to be you know and and
it's certainly not what um I think some
some people in the media would want it
to be you know there is a let's talk the
church down let's talk Faith down you
know it's dying out there is a sort of a
um you know an Orthodoxy of uh
of you know um uh secularism do you
think that's
because the elite classes are populated
disproportionately by people who are of
that secular world view yeah that's an
that's an interesting point many many
civil servants that I spoke to and if if
you take our civil servants and and the
BBC if you just take those
two people who work at the BBC and civil
servants they pretty much come from the
same stock you know red brick
universities from the home counties you
know but many of them have a faith and
this is the this is the infuriating
thing many of these people would have a
faith but it would be very private they
would go to their church on Sunday or
they would go to the um synagogue or
they'd go to their mosque and they
wouldn't bring it to work with them but
they would bring other aspects of their
life you know wanting to be very modern
and they would bring their whole self to
work whatever that might be but Faith
does seem to sort of there was a there's
a sort of a feeling well you've got to
privatize it um and that may may not be
the right thing but I mean I'm not
convinced that um um that these people
necessarily are devout
secularists um but they certainly many
of them go along with a secular
worldview probably just to keep the
peace no one wants to get fired right
for stepping outside of goes back to
what I said earlier you don't want to
step outside the Orthodoxy of the the
the what you're
in but you know faith is as I say in the
report and I think I've demonstrated
both you know empirically uh and uh
evidentially that you know faith is
actually in pretty good
health hey KK do you like trigger ometry
of course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our raws on catchup is on locals
our raw shows still go out at 7:00 p.m.
UK time 2:00 p.m. Eastern as normal but
if you want to watch them after this
time then you're going to need to sign
up to our locals Ross have now become
too spicy to stay on YouTube so they're
only available to watch back on our
locals page all you need to do to sign
up is click on the link below this video
and for just $7 a month you have access
to All of This brilliant content $7 a
month even for someone of my persuasion
that's a bargain see you all on
locals so what were some of the key
recommendations in terms of things that
we need to change in relation to Faith
well one of I mean look one of the key
things and mean I've said this in other
interviews but if there was only one
there 22 recommendations if there was
only one recommendation that this
government should introduce and do it
quickly and that is to tackle forced and
coercive
marriage so we have thousands and
thousands of typically uh women but not
not
exclusively um British women who are
forced or coerced into marrying someone
against their will and it's like it's
just
as um it's like in the too difficult box
we can't deal with it you know it's it's
just too hard if we
accept that it goes on that somebody is
forced to marry someone that they don't
love who they may have never met before
then we accept that they're going to be
raped sexually assaulted and all other
kinds of travesties will happen to them
um and that should not happen in this
country every prime minister as far back
as I could find said something really
positive we must tackle the scourge of
forced marriage you know and we will do
something about no nothing's happened
nothing hardly anything the dial hasn't
moved at all the unit sits between the
home office and the foreign office and
anyone that works in government knows as
soon as you've got a department that has
two bosses it has no boss
civil servants work to a minister right
and a minister Works to a secretary of
state and if the secretary of state says
this is a
priority then it happens if they're
suddenly work to two ministers or two
secretaries of state it becomes somebody
else's problem and they don't tackle it
and I make a very very clear
recommendation in the report that
government have to get to grips with
this it happens um in all communities
there's not I mean you know there will
be I think some lazy people that say oh
it's all in one Community it's not it
happens in lots of communities um and
can you flush that out column because I
think you say there'll be lazy people
but I I think people who are not that
well educated about faith would likely
jump to assumptions so they would
there's an assumption that it would
always be within the British Muslim
Community and it does happen within the
British Muslim Community also happens in
the Gypsy Roma Community uh traveler
Community it happens uh in the Jewish
Community particularly with the ultra
Orthodox uh Jewish community
um it's it's particularly prevalent in
the um in the in the her community there
um and there are some very small and the
numbers are tiny but in some very small
Christian groups it will happen in and
then in other communities where you've
got the traditions
of arranged marriages now there's a
distinction between what is an arranged
marriage and what is a forced or
coercive
marriage but I I personally passionately
believe that if there is any coercion at
all it's a coercive marriage so if a dad
or a mom says I really would like you to
marry this person you know for whatever
reason and the daughter or the son says
no no I like you know I like so and so I
know no but this would be really good
for you that is a coercion that is
happening we've also got child marriage
that is happening particularly within
the Gypsy Roma traveler community and
how old are these children well some of
them are like 13 13 years old and it's
happening here in this country and and
government know it's happening but it's
kind of like it's just too difficult to
deal with and why is it too difficult to
deal with what's Difficult about it well
because you are opening yourself up to
um customs and practices which are
both um some will argue are religious
therefore you're not arguing with humans
you're arguing with the
almighty in whatever shape he comes um
and there are practices that in some
cases will go back hundreds if not
thousands of years and you know there
will be some groups that say we've been
around a lot longer than this government
you know governments come and go but our
faith our way of life stays the same um
and the impact that it has on women is
absolutely obscene and and you know I I
I am I some of the evidence that we
found and some of the testimony that we
received was absolutely heartbreaking
from British women who have been forced
and trapped in marriages um you know
raped abused and no one could do
anything seemingly no one could do
anything um even within the local
communities and in some cases their own
mothers um empowering it almost you know
becoming enablers of this crime because
it happened to them now I mean it's it's
adjacent to the issue of FGM female
genital mutilation I don't cover that in
my report because it's not really a
religious thing it's more of a cultural
thing but you know it's horrendous that
it happens and there are laws against it
but it still happens and what's even you
know makes it more incomprehensible to
me is that there are some mothers that
are enabling it because it happened to
them and it happened to their sisters
well it's going to you know and we have
to tackle these thorny subjects and that
requires bravery you know it requires
our politicians to be brave and
courageous they just need to find a
spine look I think everybody here is in
agreement with you the thing is with
with this particular issue of coerced
marriage is that if the I imagine it's
normally women if these women report it
to the police they put their lives in
danger and not only that they're going
to be essentially excommunicated from
their Community aren't they yeah and
that sense of shunning and
excommunication is a very powerful
weapon to keep people trapped within
coercive um you know faith-based harm or
religious harm harmful environments um
and it and you know that's there's a
whole chapter on um on on on harm that
is done within Faith communities look
the vast majority of places of worship
are amazing the vast majority of people
of Faith are amazing um they do
tremendous work there are some very very
small minorities I say there are three
types of Believers say this in the
report there are three types of
Believers there are there are True
Believers we love true Believers we can
work with True Believers of all faiths
right good decent generous kind peaceful
people and you got non-believers and
most non-believers are fine decent kind
generous people we can work with them
the third group are the make Believers
and they're the ones that cause us all
the problems it's the make believers who
use their faith as a vehicle to promote
themselves or their agenda you know they
do it for Pride or for you know for
money ego or status or whatever it might
be and they use Faith as a for these
things and government need to be really
Discerning not cynical but they need to
be really Discerning about who they
engage with who they talk to within the
faith space not just going for the first
person that puts their hand up and says
Hi I'm the local community leader talk
to me you know they need to say um no
we're going to be much more Discerning
about who we're talking to and what
we're dealing with um because there are
so many make Believers out there and
again without you know turning the
tables on you guys there are make
Believers in the comedy industry how
many people use their comedic skills for
you know for non-comedy
reasons yeah well quite a lot of them
unfortunately the thing that I found
really interesting about your report is
you were saying that there are certain
uh topics or aspects of religion that we
don't talk about we don't focus on one
of them is seek extremism there was
black nationalism in there so let's talk
a little bit about that because I don't
think I mean that to me was a was
completely surprising so um look number
one when it comes to faith-based
extremism um by far in way both in in in
destruction and quantity
impact um islamist extremism is is still
the biggest and um and I make the point
in my report that we have to acknowledge
that by far and way the biggest victim
IMS of islamist extremism are Muslims
and I don't think we're quick enough to
say look yes it affects us you know if
there's a tragedy if there's a um you
know if there is a terrorist attack you
know in one of our cities or something
of course that all affects us but the
day today grind of ongoing islamist
extremism doesn't affect me it doesn't
affect you too it
affects the majority of British Muslims
just that that chilling effect that
corrosive effect and and
and I think we need to be we need to
acknowledge that and we need to say that
you know that they are I think they are
the the biggest victims of
this um and is islamist extremism has
been done to death by lots of other
people so I didn't go into it in in um
too much detail because I only wanted to
put my energies where I felt I could say
something different where I could add
something or contribute something that
others hadn't
done the second biggest group is
um white
supremacists um
neo-nazis who will very often
use Faith as a they make Believers right
as a vehicle to promote their very
Sinister and very racist um approach and
so you have the case of some um white
supremacists and
neo-nazis literally running into mosques
eating bacon sandwiches leaving Bibles
in the mosque um barricading the door
where women are supposed to be coming
out of um uh and just generally being
you know really vile and and and and and
and and horrible and and worse examples
of this there are many many worse
examples of
this so and I'm pleased to say you know
when pretty Patel was Home Secretary she
prescribed a number of these white
supremacist Neo-Nazi groups as terrorist
organizations and she she did a
brilliant job at doing that and I
applaud her for her courage in saying
I'm not going to part up with this cuz
we had lots and lots of islamist
terrorist and extremist groups that were
prescribed as terrorist organizations
and she took I think a really courageous
decision of saying no we're going to go
after some white supremacists as well
because what they're doing is um you
know why say courageous that seems
pretty normal thing for a government to
do to go after the
announcers yeah I mean when you put it
like that it ought to be but she did it
it you know she did
it so who was the Home Secretary from
2010 to 2016 remind me it was Theresa
May those groups like The son and cre
division um and the Luft waffer or the
the atam waffer division and all these
other groups they're not very they're
not very they don't conceal
themselves they don't but no PR pretty
did and and and you know I'm a good
friend of hers and I think she did a I
think you know she was magnificent and
and she she she Ste so why suemac is the
second biggest they're second biggest
and then I think there's a massive
massive massive um Gap then between the
third biggest group in terms of who who
are they in the UK and I do say in the
report that they are seik extremists now
the vast majority of British siks
they're relatively small population the
vast majority of them are the best of
British they are over represented in
almost every
positive um indic you could look for
home ownership family staying together
academic results you know um starting
businesses
you know they're just brilliant
brilliant people they're very charitable
they're very kind they are some of the
loveliest people I've ever
met hiding amongst them is a tiny
minority who um uh who want and are
fighting for an independent seik state
in India called kistan which is roughly
the
Punjab now look I'm almost a free speech
absolutist right so I take this View and
I say it in the report people people can
believe whatever they want to believe
you can encourage people to believe what
you believe you can raise money you can
you know you can teach and educate you
can do whatever you like but what you
can't do is be coercive what you can't
do is
threaten and this group there are plenty
of siks that you know have some vague
notion that yes kistan would be quite
nice you know uh they would perhaps
argue you know the Jews have got Israel
the Christians have got the West
uh Hindus have got India you know
Muslims have got the North Africa and
and the and the gulf and um um
Pakistan uh the Buddhists have got Sri
Lanka and um um
Myanmar where's our where's our homeland
you know we we would I think there might
be some small view that that might be
the case but they wouldn't dream in a
million years of causing pain or
suffering or or being aggressive they
certainly wouldn't terrorize anyone they
certainly wouldn't be extreme in their
behavior and that's fine you know you
can believe in that if that's what you
want I mean I'm you know it's not my not
my business I'm not Indian I'm not
sik um there is a tiny minority who are
extremists and I call them PK Pro
caristan
extremists um and they are
aggressive they are um they are
threatening I mean who who are they
aggressive towards and who other seeks
primarily I mean this is kind of like
with islamists yeah it's kind of
hermetically sealed within the SE
Community I had so many when we were
doing the evidence Gathering so many
siks come to me under the promise of
anonymity to say you know our lives are
being made of misery you know our our
garas that's the gwara is the seek
Temple you know are being taken over by
these extremists you know they're
they're kind of using our local sort of
democratic means to become you know take
over the running of our Charities of the
seek Charities of the seek of the seek
goodwi waras and they're poisoning our
young people with some you know some
really Hardline extremist things and you
know they've come after me they're
really upset with me and they've written
all kinds of stuff and nonsense um Usual
Suspects saying that my reports flawed
and they don't like what I had to say
and you know that's fine um um but they
can't deny that there are lots of kistan
extreme IST and terrorist organizations
that have been prescribed by the UK by
France by Canada by America um that um
some of the stuff that you can find
quite easily on YouTube and other social
media will make a hair curl I mean it's
it's it's really obnoxious and violent
stuff and so um you know they're on thin
ice if they think that there isn't a
problem there is very much a problem it
was the kastanis that blew up the Air
India flight over you know until 911 the
kalyani extremist were the world's worst
Aviation terrorists which is why they
were prescribed as a terrorist
organization I mean they don't like they
don't like being reminded of these
things it was you know it was seek
extremists that um assassinated Indira
gandi it was seek extremists that tried
to you know cut the throat of General
bra seek um I think he was General in
the in the Indian army who was shopping
in London tried to you know they tried
to cut his throat this is like 10 years
ago so you know they can't deny that
there's an issue so we've got a few of
them yeah quite a few quite a few would
you say how many quite a yeah very same
question well well well I'm I have been
surprised at just how many so if you
were to look up um even as recently as
this year protests outside the Indian
Embassy hundreds and hundreds of siks
with a kistan Flags
um wearing you know kistan Zin zabad
t-shirts and things like this hundreds
of them protesting outside um the Indian
Embassy even pulled down the Indian flag
outside the Indian caused a huge
diplomatic uproar because they you know
the Indian Embassy said you know our
police didn't do enough to sort of
intervene I think pulled down the Indian
flag and replaced it with a kistan flag
I mean it would be like I mean I don't
know what it would be like imagine back
in the 80s some Irish nationalists going
to Delhi and going to the British
Embassy in Delhi and pulling down the
British flag and replacing it with the
Irish one or the you know the IRA flag I
mean it would have that same emotional
kind of response that we would have
that's exactly um um how they're having
it and it's a very live issue and um and
you know I I know that my report was
probably the first to really put that in
the the public domain to say here is a
big issue now to answer the second part
of your question yes there is an issue
with black nationalists no one likes to
talk about it but there are some really
wacky groups um uh and they
interestingly they prisons are quite
fertile places for for for these groups
Nation Nation of Islam who you'll be
familiar
with um um mainstream Muslims would say
they're not Islamic then there's a group
who um they believe pretty much the same
thing but think that they're Jewish I
think they're called the um the black he
black HEB Black Hebrew Israelites um
mainstream Jews would say they're not
Jewish and then there's a Christian
group um and they all pretty much
believe the same thing and most
mainstream Christians would say but they
know they're not they're and they're
pretty racist and they're pretty
obnoxious um and look I'm not a
psychologist I I I can have an armchair
view of perhaps why some of this might
happen but um you know they're in there
I mean again all I'm saying in the
report is it's not a major problem but
it's something government just needs to
have their eyes on particularly in
prison because there's a lot of well
this is what I was going to ask you we
got to wrap up because we're running out
of time but one of the things that does
seem to be a problem uh and this isn't
specific just to islamism but Force
conversion you know the prison
population seems to be
disproportionately very religious and
that is kind of suspect to me in many
way so talk to us about that yeah so it
is if you were to take the prison
population as a whole it is much more
religious and has a much higher number
have a faith than than the rest of the
country which goes counter to your
argument about how faith is good for
society but car well no because just
joking you see I think some of them um
uh uh will will will do it because they
want to have belonging when they're when
they're in when that's all was that's
all and I think um but when they're but
when they're in prison so there's this
this idea there are some wings and I did
I did a lot of prison visits um when I
was doing the evidence Gathering um and
they they're Grim places I mean you know
prisons are not nice places at all you
know and the prison
staff I mean it's a horrible job and I'm
you know I'm glad that someone's doing
it um but you go on some wings and it
will be like a Muslim wing and it will
be a convert or get hurt you know there
will be a there will be uh and most by
the way most
the vast majority of mainstream British
Muslims would
be you know horrified by this they would
say these people are not they're not
they're not speaking for us you know and
I and I and I and I and I buy that these
are it's basically gangs these are you
know you're in the Muslim gang and
you'll get protection from or you know
you're in the islamist gang and you'll
get protection from um um from from the
others these are horrible horrible
places but convert or get hurt there'll
be a copy of the Quran on your bed and
you'll be expected to you know um tocum
and they're not the only ones I mean so
there will be other as I said the you
know there was some evidence to say that
um uh you know some of the the black
supremacists will be will be doing
similar you know similar
exercises um but the whole notion of and
and my you know i' encourage your
viewers and your listeners to download
the report and read it it'll take about
8 hours because it's quite a big thing
um but um there's there's there's quite
a lot that I have to say about faith in
prisons and um you know how and
chaplaincy in prisons can be a really
positive Force for good um and I'd like
to see government make some you know
make some changes to that as well Colin
it's been an absolute pleasure the hour
has flown by we always end our
interviews with the same question which
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should
now I have pondered this and there was
there were two answers I was going to
give so I'm going to give you two okay
allow me I think the first is the issue
of critical minerals Rare Earth and
critical minerals this is the new oil
right um like
70% of Europe's critical minerals the
stuff that we need for our mobile phones
and for um you know our uh
our uh technology and the big wind farms
and things like 70% of them uh are on
the um eastern border of Ukraine just
you
know I'm not surprised Russia wants it
so critical minerals Rare Earth minerals
and the supply chain of them China have
got
us by the short and curlies on this not
just us the whole of the West America
has been asleep Europe has been asleep
we have been asleep we need need a
healthy supply chain of these critical
minerals um to make stuff and at the
moment nearly all of that supply chain
90% of it comes through China either the
processing or the M the mining of it and
that's a massive problem because it
means that they want to turn it off
we've got a problem and then the the the
second one is
similar it's um state sponsored
industrial espionage M um you know the
amount of Ip that we have in this
country whether it's in Pharmaceuticals
or whether it's in defense or whether
it's in you know high tech or that kind
of thing intellectual property yeah
intellectual property that is being
stolen by other states uh is eyew
watering and you know um my next report
is actually on this subject on state
sponsored um industrial Espionage and
The more I've looked into it the more I
get into it the more I think this is a
massive massive massive problem and
people should be talking about it but no
we're going to fixate with you know the
latest I don't know whatever tabloid
issue there might be there are really
big important issues that are happening
right under our nose whether it's
critical minerals whether it's state
sponsored industrial Espionage and other
things a lot of your guests have said
other interesting things as well and
we've got to focus on that we've got to
get to grips with it Colin Bloom thank
you very much uh head on over to locals
where we continue the conversation with
your questions
I think this same mom
[Music]
said Leo's got the video of it I'm glad
this is on your um this is only
[Music]
your